this video is sponsored by Squarespace
imagine a scenario where a fallen
protagonist stares down his impending
doom it is darkest our health arrives in
the form of a mighty hero complete with
awesome music and much fanfare the
rescuer then lays the smackdown on the
bad guys I'm sure we've seen some
version of this scene in one way or
another already anime is chock-full of
them some have done these scenes well
while others not so much
in this video we'll be looking at some
of the top heroic rescues you sure are
glad you have those guys in your side
aren't you feeling enraged by you be
insulting shoot knuckle prepares a punch
that would demolish the Chimaera and
unfortunately for him though he played
right into his opponents hands using his
force against him yupi turns the batter
around and puts the pompadour man on the
verge of death thankfully kilowatts
timely arrival saves knuckles from his
grim fate the animation for this scene
is just superb with all those angles
graphic effects and foe symbolism
looking at it without spoilers and
having no idea of what's gonna come next
you think that Shirley knuckles done
fourth that's what makes these rescue
scenes so exciting you see you have a
slight idea that ones coming but when it
does it still leaves you with goosebumps
I'm not the only one who thought that
knuckle was gonna die am i thanks
kilowatt
[Music]
we all know episode 19 of demon slayer
all too well now don't we who doesn't in
the next episode we get the epic scene
of gear Tomioka saving tangi road since
the start of the series tangi rows
probably being the Demon Slayer corpses
water pillars only real friend and
Tomioka saves our MC in his time of need
coming in at a crucial moment Tomioka
stands as a worthy opponent to the white
demon who's been a thorn in the kymaro
siblings side for those doubting Tommy
ouka strength this episode puts that to
rest the powerful Demon Slayer
demonstrates the difference between him
and Ruby by showing off his abilities
before easily winning the battle and
eliminating the white demon
the plaque Falls coming in to save their
squadmate is seventh on the list fin
world's most important battle comes in
the crystal destruction battle
tournament practically grown as rivals
to each other federal and languorous
finally get their chance at a showdown
now despite friend rules brave showing
faith wouldn't smile down on him as he
falls in battle to his superior brother
after the match then languish rub salt
in the wound commenting that there's
nothing that his inferior brother can
beat him up before he can even finish
mineral incomes Magna Luck and hasta
it's not about the tournament anymore
now the black bulls just step in to
protect their friend from harm
[Music]
[Music]
now tell me you saw this coming even
before seeing this episode I knew
something like this was definitely gonna
happen if there's anyone who'd pull out
a last-minute save of RZA it's got to be
her trustworthy partner hasn't him after
thinking that the colonel died Reiser
loses the composure that she's known for
and unloads on the homunculus it's too
bad though her opponents someone who
wouldn't die even if you killed her
despite Alphonsus heroic attempts of
protecting her things were looking bleak
for the good guys when they're still
completely alive Mustang shows up at the
last moment revealing the secret to him
surviving his wounds Mustang burns lush
repeatedly unfazed by her continuous
regeneration even the toughest of the
homonculus has to have a limit to its
regeneration and after reviving so many
times must finally succumbs and dies in
an ironic twist at the hands of a man
who never fell for her wiles
talk about David versus Goliath standing
face to face with a giant armed with a
sword capable of cleaving anything in
half
yahiko shouts his friend's name just in
the nick of time help arrives in the
form of an unexpected rescuer badass
music heralds the entrance of the
strongest character in the Ruhr oni
Kenshin universe tensions master hiko
stops the giants powerful sword he then
shows why he's the strongest by winning
the battle against Fuji at least he paid
respect to his opponent before finishing
him off in just one hit so powerful that
he had to be kept out of the main plot
[Music]
rounding out the pre top three at number
four is Ichigo saving Rukia if this
moment seems familiar it's because you
watch the top ten bleach moments video
then you've got your internet cookie you
see those who are a bit older will
recall when times were simpler in Bleach
this moments the pinnacle of the
renowned soul society arc
Ichigo steps between the gigantic
Phoenix that's about to kill Rukia
showing never-seen-before strength and a
renewed resolve forged from his journey
Ichigo stops the being of pure energy
right before or hell's about to break
loose the calm and confident look on
ichigo's face is the look of a strong
protector one who's overcome trials to
get to exactly where he is and this
awesome moment of saving Rukia is one of
his personal highlights in the entire
series does gennych does it yeah yeah
opening our top three is a scene from
the third berserk movie it's fair to say
the skull might totally stole the
spotlight in this scene we've just seen
the rise of femto in the Eclipse but for
some the arrival of the new Lord of
Darkness is a warm-up for the epic
moment that comes next on entering the
Eclipse skull light rides through the
minions of darkness with the goal of
rescuing guts and Casca skull light
charges and leaves defeated apostles in
his wake
even femme toes attempted attack fails
to faze him and he successfully makes
his getaway his glorious charge and
rescue adds even more to what's already
been a gripping scene just who is this
mysterious Knight really well you better
start watching buzzer to find out
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
at number two is the legendary Sinbad
coming in with the seven seas alliance
at the climax of McGee's second season
[Music]
Marky's second season ends with a battle
against a medium that wouldn't look out
of place in an actual MMO even with the
aid of the co Empire things were looking
bad for our heroes as the medium simply
kept shrugging off attack after attack I
told you this is an MMO boss raid right
before the medium can proceed with
heralding the second end of the world a
bolt of lightning stops it who else can
you count on to make a grand entrance
but Sinbad king of the seven seas Sinbad
and the seven seas Alliance launched
their attack on the medium reunions
happen and a whole plethora of cool new
Djinn equips get revealed as the battle
against the medium takes another turn in
what's already been a rollercoaster of a
final boss fight standing tall at the
top of our countdown is shanks coming in
to save Kobe and ending the marineford
war ever seen a character so strong and
badass that he stops an entire war with
just his mere presence if you haven't
then perhaps you haven't seen one piece
towards the end of the marineford war
Coby finds himself staring death in the
face Coby just finished his dramatic
speech that took all the courage in the
world however a canoe doesn't seem
impressed he simply tells Coby that
seconds have been wasted and gets ready
to kill him before a canoe strikes from
out of nowhere shanks one of the Four
Emperors interferes stepping it and
protecting Coby shanks declares the war
to be over to everyone's surprise that
finishes things that's it yeah I'm not
kidding through sheer force of
intimidation shanks ends the war that's
it no high profile defeats no flashy
one-on-one battle it's over just like
that all he said was the war's over and
it was is this one badass moment or what
about Karina Yaya
[Music]
what it taught you I do still before I
in this video I'd like to give a shout
out to this video sponsor Squarespace
Squarespace is one of the easiest to use
and beautiful website development tools
out there with 24/7 365 days support you
can find everything in one platform
there's no need to add additional
plugins no updates and no patches ever
Squarespace has tons of modern templates
to choose from that have already been
crafted by their world-class design team
and they're created with mobile devices
in mind - and employ the latest HTML CSS
and JavaScript techniques so they can be
viewed on all sorts of devices and
browsers Squarespace is offering my
viewers 10% off their first purchase
just go to Squarespace calm / Vinnie
tube that VI n I I tu be e or just click
the link in the description to sign up
and start building your online presence
today so what do you think of this one
then our heroic rescue scenes amazing or
what
be sure to comment below for your
favorite saves in anime for more content
like this leave a like subscribe and
check back for more videos soon see you
next time on vinnie tube
[Music]